para la celebración de sus 90 años
isabel segunda visión como de costumbre
un traje y un sombrero del mismo color
una imagen que se hizo icónica en su
destino no estaba al convertirse en
soberana pero en 1936 cuando su tío
eduardo octavo renunció al trono por
amor fue su padre jorge sexto quien se
convirtió en rey
la muerte súbita de su padre en 1952 la
puso en el trono tenía solo 25 años de
edad y su coronación fue vista en
televisión por más de 20 millones de
personas en todo el mundo
[Música]
tras su entronización vinieron tiempos
turbulentos la decadencia del imperio
británico poco a poco las antiguas
colonias británicas fueron reclamando su
independencia nace entonces la
mancomunidad de naciones en el reino
unido- se vive el swinging london de los
sesentas y la existencia de la monarquía
británica en pleno siglo 20 fue puesta
en entredicho
después de los cuentos de hadas los tres
hijos de la reina isabel se divorcian
uno después del otro en medio de varios
escándalos el clan real tambalea en
1997 la tragedia sacudió a la corona la
muerte de la princesa diana- sumergió el
reino en un profundo duelo mientras la
reina se escudó tras su silencio una
reacción que afectó fuertemente a los
británicos isabel segunda tardó una
semana en ordenar que las banderas
fueran puestas a media asta
quiero rendirle personalmente un
homenaje a diana ella fue un ser humano
de excepcional talento tanto en los
buenos como en los malos tiempos nunca
perdió su capacidad de sonreír y de
inspirar a otros con su calidez y bondad
con el tiempo isabel volvió a ser
popular
miles llenaron las calles para celebrar
sus jubileo en 2002 y 2012 las bodas de
los príncipes guillermo con kate
middleton y de enrique con megan marco
así como el nacimiento de los bisnietos
trajeron colorido a una monarquía
envejecida pero también la garantía de
perpetuar la tradición a través de las
futuras generaciones contó con la
empatía del público cuando perdió a su
esposo el príncipe felipe en 2021 en
febrero de 2022 su salud causó
preocupación cuando dio positivo por
kobe 19 pero lo superó e incluso dio un
discurso para dar ánimos y esperanza a
la población contra la enfermedad en
junio de 2022 llegó una fecha clave el
jubileo de platino la monarca más
longeva de la historia del país
conmemora sus 70 años de reinado en unas
festividades que duraron cuatro días con
la familia real reunida y miles de
personas siguiendo las celebraciones
aunque isabel se ausentó de varios
eventos por motivos de salud
isabel fue para muchos una fuerza que
dio estabilidad al reino unido- tanto en
los malos como en los buenos tiempos